democracy activists in Hong Kong have
launched another weekend of
anti-government protests protesters have
begun marches in to Hong Kong
neighborhoods they're also staging a
sit-in at Hong Kong Airport activists
occupied the arrivals hall and
distributed flyers to tourists and other
passengers police warned against
violence or disruptions that could
endanger public safety but reports
suggest the airport appears to be
operating normally I'm joined now from
Hong Kong by our correspondent Phoebe
Kong
Phoebe thanks for joining us we're
seeing the second day of protests at
Hong Kong Airport this weekend but
overall they appear more peaceful what's
your take
and there are various formats of
protests happening in Hong Kong right
now or weekends you have mentioned
earlier peaceful assembly is now are
being held at the airport the aim is to
disseminate that amount and also the
latest situation of Hong Kong on to the
international community especially
through the tourists around the world
and they are like participating in
assembly in a very peaceful manner and
earlier today we also see that families
and and elderlies they are they also
talk to streets to demonstrate to the
government headquarters and this is a
way to show how different walks of life
in Hong Kong how to show the defense to
remain a deviant in these protests and
in these movements but meanwhile right
now as where I am in Tai Po notices of
this is an urban district in Hong Kong
and there are several hundreds of
protesters there now occupying the role
and there now I was trying to are to go
on the rallies that despite the fact
that the police are banned the
application of the assembly so there
might be violence crashes happening in
the coming future today so we can see
like the protesters from different
groups they are now are taking a
different approach to continue their
movement figure you have the protesters
made a conscious decision to change
their tactics after heating warnings
from both Beijing and Hong Kong's
military that they were basically
crossing red lines
yes this is the question like many
people there now are discussing in these
days because I asked a series of a very
violent clashes in the past few days and
protesters these days they are now
evaluating the effectiveness of the
previous approach and some of them they
decided to like it we are to a retreat
repeat because we can see there is a
massive depletion of manpower because
the number of the people being arrested
increased very significantly so some of
them they were rather to take some like
difference or rather peaceful approach
but that is not something but but but
that doesn't mean that they are not
given given up the radical approach
because some of them they are they are
still insisting that this kind of
radical approach is is big enough to
pressure the government so on there now
like at a stage - trying to to
reorganize their movements but I think
both tactics they would like still like
- to proceed in the future so peaceful
for now but not necessarily giving up
the radical approach
Phoebe Kong in Hong Kong thank you so
much